on va vous le prouver avec celui qui
nous a rejoint celle ami jérémy 2 mai
tout à l'heure on était vraiment sur des
découvertes culinaires là on va plutôt
s'intéresser à d'autres découvertes
parce que c'est vrai que les vacances
approchent pour certains pour d'autres
c'est déjà le cas pour nous commence à
le sentir à y penser très sérieusement
mais on peut aussi imaginer des idées
vacances parce que vous êtes branché
solidarité et des vacances pour nos
enfants ou tout simplement en famille
qu'est ce que vous nous avez trouvé
jérémy pour chez nous et bien on va
partir à la ferme à la ferme parce que
déjà c'est plutôt intéressant et surtout
il ya un programme qui s'appelle le
wwoofing le wwoofing en fait c'est du
bénévolat qui permet de partir dans des
fermes des fermes biologiques des fermes
qui pratiquent la permaculture notamment
et ça permet la biodynamie entre autres
mais ça permet aussi d'apprendre
justement ces techniques et tout ça
bénévolement d'accord vont parler de
wwoofing est ce que vous connaissez vous
le couchsurfing
non non non non non le couchsurfing
alors en fait ces deux canapés à la
maison c'est à dire qu'on prête son
canapé à la maison en échange de travaux
parce que vous pour le wwoofing c'est en
fait de donner son temps et de son
travail en échange du gîte et du couvert
exactement ça c'est une autre forme de
vacances je propose d'ailleurs de
découvrir un bel exemple de ce qui s'est
passé à vonn en côte-d'or pas loin de
mirebeau c'était il ya précisément un an
et puis nous revenons avec des vacances
solidaires en compagnie de jérémy
ensemble c'est mieux ce matin le
français n'est pas leur langue
maternelle mais elles comprennent tous
sofiane à sont originaires de budapest
en hongrie
mère et fille ont choisi le wwoofing
pour des vacances actives dans le verger
avec colt après
il y à des travaux dans le potager c'est
un bon pratique aussi c'est bien parce
que c'est une bonne pratique pour moi
dans la langue
anaëlle n'en est pas à son premier
séjour le wwoofing c'est aussi
l'occasion de gagner en expérience et de
renforcer son cv tu te souviens à
n'acheter avait parlé des courbes de
niveau oui parce que si on plante en
ligne droite
ça n'a pas du tout le même impact sur le
paysage qui s'appelait jolie comme ça
c'est plus joli dit j'aime bien la
nature je sais une horticultrice et je
voudrais pratiquer mon métier un peu la
langue aussi et l'agriculture biologique
m'intéresse beaucoup
agnès est la propriétaire des lieux les
murs bas sont les récoltes pas parce
qu'elles sont réservées aux renards non
récolte au dessus d'un mètre cette
passionnée aime partager ses
connaissances et faire découvrir son
activité
moi ce qui met et des coups de pouce
c'est aussi un dynamisme parce que les
gens s'intéressent donc quand ils
s'intéressent sam donne du courage pour
continuer après l'effort un verre de
sirop de cassis maison pour sofiane a
qui rentreront en hongrie dans un mois
mais elle était 2018 au soleil pour 2019
c'est quand même assez bien parti
faites attention pensez à bien vous
hydrater si vous pouvez comme nous vous
mettre à l'abri même si c'est un peu
moins folkloriques je pense que ça
devrait pouvoir le faire quoi qu'il en
soit vous avez fait le bon choix
vous êtes sur france3 ensemble c'est
mieux avec jérémy pourparlers solidarité
vous me disiez tout à l'heure que ont
pratiqué le wwoofing chez nous en
bourgogne franche comté j'ai envie de
vous demander en quoi c'est solidaire
dans nos fermes en bourgogne franche
comté de pratiquer le hockey glace et
solidaire tout simplement parce que
d'abord ces bénévoles est en fait comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est
aussi un échange en échange de son temps
de ses bras de deux ses mains et bien
l'hôte vous donne le gîte et le couvert
alors évidemment il faut pas travailler
non plus ça reste des vacances
donc il faut pas que ça dépasse 25
heures par ce même pas qu'il vienne
subordination de hiérarchie fin bref
c'est ce que définit le code du travail
pour définir ce qu'est un travail
rémunéré donc là vu que c'est du
bénévolat il faut éviter de tous ces
débordements du travail entre guillemets
normal voilà parce que là le principe
c'est quand même d'être en vacances et
de donner de son temps et bénévolement
éviter bien entendu il ya un toit il y à
l'assiette
il ya beaucoup de fermes en bourgogne
franche comté germi y en aurait à peu
près 75 qui qui propose ce ce type de
service donc il n'ya plus du côté franc
comtois que du côté bourguignon pour le
coup mais il y en a comme une 75 dans la
région comment est ce qu'on les trouve
ces fermes parce que ce kit ans avec
nous et qui nous regardent se disent il
est très gentil jérémy mais on fait
comment alors il ya plusieurs sites
internet qui propose sa bombe ouf point
frw of two 2 o -f point fr alors en fait
il ya deux types de personnes il y a le
bénévole qui est donc un bouffeur et l
autre et voilà que par définition c'est
lui qui est qui reçoit pourront s'évader
on va dire à prendre prendre du bon
temps pour pas cher
il faut quand même un petit peu de
travail et on l'a vu dans le reportage
vous l'avez sous-entendu voilà c'est pas
c'est pas comme nous aujourd'hui en mode
vacances quoi non mais l'avantagé du
site gouv.fr c'est qu'on peut choisir
son type de fermes céréalières animal
élevage ou autre on se choisit aussi la
durée du séjour une semaine deux
semaines trois semaines il faut juste
payer une adhésion de 25 euros si on est
tout seul 30 euros si on est deux donc
bon ça reste quand même plutôt
raisonnables et bien sûr il faut pas
travailler plus de 25 heures par semaine
sinon bien ça devient du travail
rémunéré et là en l'occurrence si c'est
du bénévolat qui dépasse 25 heures c'est
du travail dissimulé donc pour ça il
faut faire attention mais maintenant
tout est encadré notamment par la msa et
est donc il n'ya pas de souci là-dessus
utilité sociale agricole tracts très
bien pendant les vacances on peut aussi
se plonger dans dans notre histoire dans
les musées y en a un très très beau à
besançon il ya un très très beau à dijon
puis un peu partout en bourgogne franche
comté
on peut effectivement les profiter des
climatisations des musées et puis des
endroits assez frais ça fait du bien oui
on peut même aller à l'extérieur
justement pour rencontrer de l'histoire
in situ c'est à dire là où elle est il
ya plusieurs associations qui proposent
ça on peut aller sur les sites internet
des cris je vous savez les cetc centaine
journaux d'information jeunesse a chuté
à trois choix des enfants nathalie donc
on va dans les crises on peut se
renseigner mais on peut aller
directement aussi sur certains sites
internet par exemple sainte colombe en
auxois où assa romain ça c'est en côte
d'or et on peut aller réparer des
remparts travailler sur sur l'histoire
là où elle est ce qui est plutôt
intéressant aussi j'ai entendu parler de
mes récits mauron vous savez c'est pas
très très loin d'eux
c'est au sud de mamirolle et
un chanteur très connu café the voice
vous rappelez peut-être c'est lilian
renault qui originaire du doubs là bas
il se passe quelque chose justement là
bas aussi
oui tu tous les ans il ya un super
chantier qui s'appelle un chantier
solidaire autour des sentier karstique
alors le cast vous savez c'est ce
calcaire qui recouvre certains chemins
et notamment le lit du doubs est en fait
en les rénovant et bien on peut
permettre aux non seulement de les
entretenir tout simplement mais aussi de
pouvoir se promener donc l'appareil
c'est un chantier solidaire s'est ouvert
aux jeunes donc c'est à merris ou moraux
et c'est plutôt intéressant
il ya aussi quelque chose de plus
qu'intéressant à rappeler c'est que
pendant les vacances la solidarité c'est
aussi envers nos amis à quatre pattes et
puis nos animaux en général parce que
malheureusement et là en aidant dans un
véhicule un caisson ses roulés mais bon
pour les besoins de la télévision on est
arrêté tranquillement au plein air ici
en bourgogne france comté
on imagine que les animaux que l'on
pourrait transporter ici on pouvait
aussi avoir tendance à les abandonner à
les laisser y en a de plus en plus lui
vous connaissez la chanson vacances
j'oublies tout est malheureusement aussi
ces animaux d'ailleurs la france est
championne d'europe 1 au niveau de la
bande ont donc c'est quand même assez
abjecte comme comme comportement alors
qu'il existe plein de solutions si
effectivement on ne peut pas emmener son
animal en vacances et bien on peut
l'emmener la spa attention c'est pas du
tout pour l'abandonner car il y ait des
parties pension qui permettent en plus
d'être solidaire puisque on permet de
donner un peu d'argent à l'espé à notre
animal et gardez donc c'est plutôt tout
bénef
merci jérémy je précise que nos amis les
bêtes mesdames messieurs on va en parler
mercredi avec notre ami vétérinaire et
peut-être bien justement vous allez
emmener vos animaux en vacances auquel
cas il faut penser à plein de choses on
en parlera avec l'ami jean jacques burns